thataboy you've presented earlier today
about the digital revolution I think
there were four points you were making
to the conference can you take us
through those sure so basically we're
talking about digital revolution and an
impact on the telecom industry and the
TMT industry in general the first point
is about what is actually changing and
we believe that lots of things will
change from the way that the networks
are owned and operated to the way that
the service is actually consumed by the
customer the second point is what the
industry needs to think about what the
regulators and the general community
needs to think about how the industry is
structured what may change in the
regulation and and so on the third point
is specifically about what policies may
need to be amended and how the policies
may need to be amended in order to
support the digital economy and and
support the internet or broadband
networks rollouts and the fourth point
is something that we've done some work
on in the past is on the infrastructure
light or if you want infrastructure
separated business models in in in
telecoms and what has been happening
around the world in the past 24 months
or or 18 months which is which is quite
significant developments that we're
talking about it Toni bit more about
infrastructure like I've not heard of
that before well we discussed it in our
notes which is called rebirth of telecom
monopoly in November 2014 since then
we've seen major development as I said
more than forty percent of the towers
around the world are now outside the
telecom companies in specialised tower
companies we've seen apart from the New
Zealand situation which is well known we
saw a full structural separation first
in the world including fixed and mobile
and voluntary basis of 02 czech republic
but we see a number of other companies
whether it's telefonica which is now
talking about splitting some some
assets in Western Europe we're talking
Ofcom looking at the situation in the UK
we saw the Mexican regulator essentially
auctioning 700 megahertz spectrum to
with the assumption of an open network
we saw the u.s. operated some of them
considering service focused strategies
of the emphasizing the the
infrastructure we saw that debate in
Turkey so there's really lots of lots of
developments China I shouldn't forget as
well that essentially separated all
their towers and thinking about other
other infrastructure so that's that's a
global trend in our view and there will
be more developments and more news on in
that area yeah absolutely another point
you made was about regulatory issues
because they're very important as well
you know what's your view on how
regulatory issues need to perhaps change
to make the market demands yes so the
essence of the regulation in our view is
looking at potential failures of
competition because since the
liberalization of the telecom market in
the 80s and 90s competition has been the
crucial policy in across all the
infrastructure and services and spectrum
and essentially all the asset classes so
the question is where competition works
and where it may not work and why and
the second thing is opening of the
networks or universal if you want open
access now I think both policies have
been in place competition has worked in
some areas more than in other areas and
I think there are certain issues in
certain infrastructure where where
competition seems to be failing and in
terms of the open the openness of the
networks I think the main policy that
has so far been in place is is net
neutrality now both concepts the full
competition and net neutrality in the
way that was introduced in the 80s and
90s may now be revealed or is being
discussed in in different occasions and
in
in the industry and we believe that
there are certain opportunities for the
regulators to to revisit these issues
that doesn't mean stop net neutrality or
stop network openings but that could
mean open the networks at the lower
layers let's say the basic
infrastructure rather than only focusing
on the ISP layer by that we can get the
benefit of sharing infrastructure but we
can also and as a consequence of that we
could encourage more service competition
and I think what's important is that the
service competition in the future is
going to be far more interesting than in
the past because in the Internet of
Things environment the types of services
that our products that need connectivity
the the range is going to be far wider
yes it's going to be it's going to make
a big impact isn't it in IOT I think
it's going to change everything and it's
it's it's important that both the
shareholders of the operators and the
operators themselves work with the
regulators on what we call symbiotic
solutions when returns can be made on
the investment in the operators but at
the same time the opportunity to grow
the digital economy is maximized as well
fantastic thank you very much for
joining us thank you